>> AS IF WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PROBLEMS IN THIS
LIKE A DEMON EVER SINCE
LOCAL OFFICIALS IN PALM
SPRINGS IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
IDENTIFIED A GROUP OF TREES
AT A LOCAL GOLF COURSE AS
BEING RACIST.
WE HAVE BEEN SEEING THOSE
KIND OF TREES EVERYWHERE.
IS IT COINCIDENCE THAT A
PINE TREE RESEMBLES A
KLANSMANHOOD WHAT WAS THE
NOT OTHER TREES COMPLICIT IN
THIS RADIO HOST JOINS US.
LARRY, WHAT'S GOING OUT
THERE IN PALM SPRINGS IF YOU
COULD SUM IT UP FOR US?
>> I THINK IT'S CLIMATE
CHANGE.
IT'S HARD TO SAY, TUCKER.
THIS IS CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS WHERE THE GOVERNOR
JUST SIGNED HIKE UP THE
WAGES TO $15 AN HOUR AFTER
ADMITTING THAT MINIMUM WAGE
MEASURES DON'T MAKE MUCH
GO FIGURE.
IT'S ABOUT MAKING BLACK
PEOPLE FEEL BETTER ABOUT THE
PAST ABOUT JIM CROW AND
A NEWS BULLETIN FOR 30 OR 40
YEARS BLACKS SCORE HIGHER ON
SELF-ESTEEM.
THE SUICIDE RATES FOR WHITES
IS HIGHER THAN FOR BLACKS.
THE ISSUE IS NOT WHETHER
BLACKS FEEL GOOD OR BAD
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT THAT
PART OF BLACK AMERICA NOT
DOING WELL.
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHITE
RACISM OR RACIST TREES.
BLACK KIDS ARE RACED WITHOUT
FATHERS.
I DIDN'T SAY IT OBAMA SAID
IT A KID RAISED WITHOUT A
NINE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
DROP OUT OF SCHOOL, 20 TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO END UP IN
JAIL.
WHAT'S MAKING SO MANY WOMEN
MARRY THE GOVERNMENT AND MEN
THAT OUGHT TO BE THE
CONVERSATION BUT IT ISN'T.
>> Tucker: IT NEVER IS YOU
ARE SCOLDED FOR BRINGING IT
UP.
ENORMOUSLY SAD.
I FIND IT SO INTERESTING
GROWING UP IN CALIFORNIA
AROUND LIBERALS THERE WAS
REALLY NO GREATER SIN THAN
CUTTING DOWN A TREE.
THEY WERE CALL TREE HUGGERS,
LITERALLY.
>> THESE ARE RACIST TREES
DOES NOT SUPPORT VOUCHERS.
EVEN THOUGH THE MAJORITY OF
URBAN PARENTS, BLACK AND
BROWN WANT VOUCHERS.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
OPPOSED TO VOUCHER, YET 95%
OF BLACK PEOPLE PULL THE
LEVER FOR PEOPLE PUD
EDUCATION FOR THINKS KIDS.
WHAT I WANT.
RATHER THAN FRIVOLOUS
THINGS.
ONE OF THE REASONS WE HAVE
HIGHLIGHT THE RACEST TREE
STORY IS BECAUSE IT SO
SELF-EVIDENTLY STUPID MAYBE
IT WILL AWAKEN PEOPLE TO THE
WHY AREN'T WE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT TEST
SCORES AND MARRIAGE AND DRUG
USE, NOT JUST IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY BUT THIS EVERY
COMMUNITY IN AMERICA.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I REMINDED DON LEMMING WHEN
I WAS LAST ON CNN MAYBE
THAT'S WHY I WAS LAST ON IN
1997 "TIME" MAGAZINE AND CNN
DID A POLL OF BLACK TEENS
AND WHITE TEENS AND ASKED
THEM BOTH WHETHER OR NOT
RACISM WAS A MAJOR PROBLEM
IN AMERICA AND NOT TOO
SURPRISINGLY BLACK TEENS AND
RACISM IS MAJOR, MINOR
PROBLEM IN YOUR LIVES.
>> ALMOST 90% OF BLACK TEENS
SAID NO PROBLEM OR MINOR
PROBLEM IN MY OWN DAILY
LIFE.
MORE WHITE TEENS THAN BLACK
TEENS SAID FAILURE TO TAKE
RACISM.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
RACIST TREES?
TAKE A WAND AND WAVE IT OVER
AMERICA AND REMOVE EVERY
SMIDGEN OF RACISM FROM THE
THEY CAN'T TAKE CARE OF.
MEN ABANDONING
RESPONSIBILITY.
GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS THAT
DON'T WORK.
BAD POLICIES LIKE MINIMUM
ILLEGAL WORKERS UNSKILLED
CHALLENGING WORKERS IN THE
INNER CITY AND ON AND ON AND
ON.
THOSE FACING AMERICA.
LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THEM.